does your family mind you seem like such
a nice fellow well raised you I'm
imagining you have a nice family do they
mind that you're on a TV show where
you're so mistreated your character is
so mistreated no I think frankly I love
my family I think they enjoy it a little
bit but they they don't mind the insults
that come at me this is a hundred
percent true I think the ones that they
throw at Tony Hale they that affects
them more but because Tony is Tony's
their favorite actor on the show Tony
Hale on the show is my mom's favorite
actor even though I am on it cuz we were
we were preferred Tony Hale to her son
yes because she was on Arrested
Development so I we come from an
Arrested Development family and so I
don't think there's anything that is
ever going to upstage that for it
frankly right now you are my mom's
favorite person on this talk how so my
parents definitely do not mind me
getting made fun of and actually I am
currently embroiled in like a family
text chain I am being roasted by my
family right now because I looked I
looked at the Eclipse earlier this week
I did the thing where I like looked up
at the Eclipse and I and wouldn't have
done it I know and I know that
everybody's making fun of Donald Trump
for doing it and that I know that I am
hypocritical somewhat in the fact that I
have made fun of Donald Trump for doing
that but I just I want to say that at no
point I know it wasn't the right thing
to do but at no point over the last five
years nor into the future will I ever
try to tell you or spend money trying to
convince you that I am smart enough to
be the leader of the free world and I
feel like there's a separation fine if
you make fun of me for doing that right
but that's yeah you don't even know what
talk show you're on right now I do know
I even it's so
versus Allen I've never been on that all
I know is I think they danced yeah
you